today's questions from Hannah and
Virginia she says I want to start a
family but my husband wants to wait
until we can afford it
and we are on a budget and the only debt
we have is his truck and the usual bills
we own our home we've been married two
years going on three what's your opinion
when do you think we should have a baby
he makes on average to $2,500 every two
weeks and I'm a stay-at-home wife well
Virginia we always recommend whether
it's getting married having a baby you
do it on yours on your plan the money
stuff comes second
you have to know obviously that babies
cost money they're expensive
probably the where you are financially
is going to determine probably the
stress that comes with all of that as
well so if you're in a better place
financially obviously the stress of
having a baby is a little bit lower but
that should not stop you from having one
so your family planning needs to be on
your time and I mean yeah you guys I
would if that's your only debt you have
is this truck I would just pause paying
on that stay current on it don't pay
extra on it and then save up pile up a
big emergency fund to the bank well you
want when you get pregnant and then
after you come home baby comes home go
ahead and just throw the rest at the
truck but waiting till there's a
quote/unquote good time to have a kid
there probably never will be something
in life always is going to be in the way
there's always going to be something so
yeah if I were you guys and you want a
baby go have a baby there you go you and
God decide when the money doesn't decide
but you do need to be on the same page
and you do need a plan and you do need
to be executing the plan together that's
just good exercise for your relationship
and your money I mean if you're doing
all of that then that does lower the
stress if the only thing you've got left
is the truck payment and you pay it pay
aggressively on the truck until you're
pregnant like Rachel said and then stop
paying everything but the minimums and
then pile up cash until baby comes and
yeah exactly so we don't tell people to
wait to get married or to wait to have
kids until they're out of debt never
have in 30 years of doing this show it's
just inconsistent with the way we've
lived our lives and one of the things
we're real careful about
here is we don't we don't suggest to you
anything that we haven't done or aren't
willing to do or that is inconsistent
with the way I'm currently living or
something like that so you know when I
tell you to drive a hoopty for instance
and I drove a hoopty you know I drove an
old piece-of-crap car while I was
getting out of debt
so I'm nasty and do something I haven't
done same thing when folks work on our
team here almost every job in this
building with the exception of computer
programming I have done or am willing to
do and I'm not too proud to set up
chairs I'm not too proud about stack
boxes into a truck if I need to I don't
do those things today but I'm not too
proud to and I'm not too proud to ask
you to do it if it's your job and so
same thing with you guys you're not too
proud to ask you that you know you're
gonna have to sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next you're going to
be live on beans and rice and daven sure
and Remzi did that and so or not and
rachel and winston cruz would be willing
to if they found themselves in that mess
in order to get there and so they know
how to pay a price to win and that's
what that's what is necessary in this
process